leading the group of official duty  person makes now you can see president  from and Melania here we are  come on a blue tie you know the  president doesn't like staircases so  he's going rather gingerly  shaking around the Ambassador there  speaking to the Queen's Lord in Waiting  having been introduced by the Lord  Lieutenant and now shaking the hands of  Jeremy Hunt the foreign secretary  [Music]  like mr. hunt will be anxious for that  chatter on camera to go on as long as it  possibly can well he was one of the  people who at president's um please talk  about favorably obviously Boris Johnson  seems to be his preferred candidate in  this new leadership race that he did  have some warm words to Jeremy Hammond  Police Chief Constable Ben Julian  Harrington the chief counselor Essex  and finally Stephen Griffiths at the end  of that row he's the chief operating  officer of Stansted Airport